I like it I like the organization here
of the consulate they treat people well
and it was fast no no we give a lot of
time I feel very good as I have not
taken the vaccine
I got it in December and the truth is
that I did have a very bad time well
my  family and everyone was very
scared,
the truth is that if I consider it very
important that we get vaccinated
for contacts, we have to respect the
eligibility groups that are
opening up and remember that the vaccine is
free, it is safe and that it has nothing to
do with  Immigration, whether or not you have
papers in this country, if you live here and you
have to get the vaccine,
please get it, today they
are modernizing these vaccination sessions,
we do them as a team with the city of Las
Vegas, so it depends on the vaccine
that is available.  the one they bring